bienvenidos a la entrevista aquí en
france man cartera nos encontramos hoy
con el ministro de transformación
digital en mihaylov de droga
muchas gracias por estar hoy con
nosotros
ministro nos puede explicar que es el
ejército de internet y qué tácticas está
usando en los ataques contra rusia
desde el primer día de la guerra hemos
reunido a casi 300.000 ciber
profesionales de todo el mundo para
contraatacar a rusia en el ámbito de la
ciberseguridad online
y contrarrestar los ataques que se están
llevando a cabo en chile la especialista
de compañía tak ine publica topos
online
más pronto puedo preguntarle qué tipo de
ataques son son ataques de o s son otro
tipo de ataque
en el caso de las operaciones públicas
es más 2
pero también pueden ser ataques a
sistemas de información sitios
específicos y ataques más complejos
por otra parte si le puedo preguntar
cómo el sistema de internet de ucrania
ha logrado resistir a los ataques que
vienen de rusia
hemos documentado cientos de ataques
mensuales durante estos dos años y medio
pero también hemos construido un sistema
que puede contrarrestar estos ataques
la mejor prueba es que lanzamos nuevos
servicios semanalmente servicios para el
gobierno y los ciudadanos
está usted hablando también de los
satélites starling de los más que si no
puede explicar cómo los está usando
ucrania
a
una conexión a internet estable es una
parte esencial de las actividades de
contraataque hemos restablecido el
internet de banda ancha y el wifi además
nuestra infraestructura está protegida
gracias a la conexión por satélite y
siempre tenemos una conexión del
respaldo para mantener al país conectado
en abonos es que no está usted usando
también para el ejército
sin duda en lugares donde no hay una
buena conexión los militares lo usan
para mantenerse en contacto con sus
familias
y tenemos las pruebas fotográficas en
las redes sociales pero el objetivo
principal que es apoyar la
infraestructura
constructor me podría hablar de cómo usa
su gobierno las cripto monedas que
realmente se trata de un recurso para
ucrania en esta guerra
si hemos creado la primera cripto
fundación para ayudar al ejército y al
país hemos recaudado más de 60 millones
de dólares para apoyar a las fuerzas
armadas el sistema de salud las
instituciones y los ciudadanos los
activos virtuales están usando
activamente
se espera que la guerra cibernética
empeore en los próximos meses son los
próximos años
después
ya como eso es una buena pregunta yo
yo creo que empeorará el número de
ataques pero no en pérdidas ni problemas
[Música]
pero por eso tenemos que seguir
invirtiendo en construir y apoyar el
sistema de ciberseguridad
usted es el jefe de esta de este
ejército de internet
es una asociación de voluntarios que es
autosuficiente y sólo necesita ser
coordinada por lo que la estructura no
es vertical cada uno de los
participantes es un comandante en jefe o
cosas que
su país está preparado para luchar está
sin ver guerra del futuro
[Música]
creo que nadie pudo prever que
tendríamos una conexión a internet que
los servicios funcionarían de manera
estable y que lanzaríamos nuevos
servicios semanalmente
por lo tanto si estamos listos para
luchar activamente en este campo y ganar
un huevo
le estaba haciendo esta pregunta porque
me gustaría saber cuáles son sus
principales preocupaciones de cara al
futuro
a pesar de nuestros resultados en el
campo de la ciberguerra tenemos que
invertir más tiempo
y fuerza en él para seguir ganando
sistemáticamente como una inversión de
42 lotes externo la noche último robot
es externo moto botas estamos aquí versa
gesto para mojado
muchas gracias por esta entrevista